نذر الموت تتهدد المرضى والجرحى في
مستشفيات قطاع غزه فلقد اوشك الوقود على
النفاد ربما خلال ثلاثه ايام تؤكد وكاله
الامم المتحده لغوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
الفلسطينين
اونروا تصف الوكالات الامميه الوضع
بالكارثي لكن الحقيقه ان الماساه تخطت ذلك
الوصف فرفض اسرائيل ادخال الوقود يعني
وفاه فئات من المرضى بانقطاع الاكسجين
عنهم واخرين بتوقف عمل كلاهم نتيجه تعطل
اجهزه غسيل الكلاء وانعدام الوقود يعني
انقطاع الكهرباء عن غرف العمليات وعن سائر
الاجهزه الطبيه فهذه منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله يونيسيف تعلن ان 120 مولودا جديدا
موضوعين في حاضنات باتوا معرضين للخطر
بسبب النقص الحاد في الوقود اللازم لتشغيل
مولدات الكهرباء في المستشفيات وبلا وقود
تتعطل المخابز وهي بالفعل اصبحت محدوده
ولا تلبي احتياجات السكان لا سما بعد ان
قصفت طائرات الاحتلال عده مخابز وقتلت
عشرات الفلسطينيين ممن كانوا يحاولون
التزود بالخبز وتمتد الاثار الكارثيه لنقص
الوقود الى محطات تصفيه المياه والصرف
الصحي حيث اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه ان حالات الاصابه بالجدر
المائي والجرب والاسهال تتزايد بين السكان
جراء اضطرارهم لاستخدام مياه غير صالحه
وحذرت المنظمه الدوليه من تفشي تلك
الامراض اذا لم يتم الاسراع باعاده تزويد
مرافق المياه والصرف الصحي بالكهرباء او
الوقود اهل القطاع يتهددهم ايضا شبح الموت
جوعا اذ حذرت المديره التنفيذيه لبرنامج
الاغذيه العالمي سندي ماكين من ان الحصار
المستمر على غزه يدفع اكثر من مليونين
و300 ال نسمه الى حافه
المجاعه وامام هول الماساه متعدده الاوجه
وعجز العالم او ربما تقاعسه عن لجم
اسرائيل قلل مدير الطوارئ في منظمه الصحه
العالميه مايكل راين من قيمه قافله
المساعدات التي دخلت القطاع حتى الان
مشددا على ان حاجه السكان هناك لا تقل عن
2000 شاحنه وبمعدل 100 شاحنه يوميا على
الاقل